hey everybody and welcome to another hd
tutorial in this video i'll be showing
you by request how to get the divx codec
for the cam studio screen recorder now
i'm actually using camtasia studio 6 to
actually record
how to use the how to get the codec for
cam
cam studio stream recorder excuse me so
in order to know what codec you have
obviously you can click on options go to
video options and you will see right
there i'm using the divx 6.8.5 codec for
all my cam studio videos so i'm going to
hit ok
and in order to get this codec i'm going
to show you guys just open any internet
browser you'd like for this one i'm
going to use safari just because of its
speed
and go to any popular search engine and
type in divx
d i v x
and the first one divx.com
once you get to divx.com you're
obviously going to see the new dx
there's going to be a free download and
by divx pro we're just going to get the
free download here so click on that
it'll open up in a new window saying do
you want to get the divx installer and
that is exactly what you want to do is
hit the open button and that's it so i
already have it so i hit cancel
once you do this it will automatically
inject itself basically into cam studio
and you always have on the divx codec
whenever you record now here's obviously
the steps uh since you clicked on that
link it knows you've downloaded it so
here are the steps that you take
afterwards you can select the language
that you actually installed in and then
the divx installer will throw it into
any screen recorder you're actually
using that's it
so thanks for the request and uh the
requester's name and channel will be in
the description box to your right or if
you're watching in hd it's down and
further down so that's basically it
thanks for watching and subscribe and if
you have any other comments or tutorials
that you want me to do just go ahead and
leave drop me a comment subscribe to my
page and i will handle it the best that
i possibly can so thanks for watching
guys peace